Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new loki video for how it just helped set up
the events of spiderman no way home doctor strange
2 and marvel's what if series which is basically
like a giant multiverse series way crazier than
what's happening on loki if you thought that
it couldn't get crazier it can definitely get
crazier if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll
be doing all the episode videos for what if
obviously a whole bunch of spider-man videos and
doctor strange 2 we're doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just post all your predictions
in the comments below careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on loki so far too
if you have not seen episodes one and two yet
but kevin feige and the loki producers revealed
that the loki series more than any other series
so far will have big ripple effects on all the
future marvel phase 4 movies and series because
of what they're doing messing with the timeline
the sacred timeline as the timekeepers call it so
at the end of loki episode 2 Sylvie Laufeydottir
sets off all these reset devices the time reset
devices is part of a larger time bomb device
sending each of them to very specific points in
history across the mcu just calculated for where
they could cause the most damage and create the
biggest amount of branch timelines rents layer
screen shows a bunch of them go by but it's only
a small fraction like if you look at the warehouse
here and this isn't even all of them in this big
shot here there's only 43 distinct charges in this
scene here and you have to imagine this entire
warehouse they said this is a giant warehouse all
the warehouse is full top to bottom with shelves
with a bunch of charges so theoretically there are
hundreds of different branch timelines now that
she just helped create but here's the thing you
probably noticed for the most part she sent all of
them to the distant past in the mcu in the recent
present she didn't really send many of them to
the future there's one of them that went to the
future on vermeer i'll explain that later in the
video it's not quite as relevant for the events
of spider-man no way home and she wasn't literally
creating the multiverse so to speak like there was
a multiverse before the events of the loki series
but what she did was important for expanding the
marvel multiverse in a really calculated way
leading into the plot of spiderman no way home
in doctor strange 2 and marvel's what if series
each of the charges were meant to create a new
nexus event so normally the time reset devices
erase changes to the timeline before they get
to a certain point and become permanent but she
just rewired them so that they did the reverse
they had that big speech at the beginning of the
episode where miss minutes is grilling loki giving
him the test like what happens when nexus events
are created that's why they say that the tva
only has a certain amount of time to reset things
before these alternate timelines become permanent
and start to function like fully alternate
realities alternate universes then the tva would
no longer be able to reset things every single tva
grunt that they have are running out to all these
different locations to try and fix them before
they become permanent but the idea is there's way
too many of them so some of them will definitely
become permanent it is all part of sylvie's plan
to destroy the timekeeper's ability to police the
timeline the sacred timeline so to speak so that
they no longer have the ability to determine
what is sacred and what is not sacred the idea
being that she came from one of these other branch
timelines that they deemed too dangerous were not
good enough to be part of their sacred timeline
so they erased it but she survived somehow then
started her quest to burn it all to the ground
so to speak i think that's why they also had
that funny line of dialogue from loki which seems
more like him doing a babe ruth call out at the
beginning of episode one i'm gonna burn this place
to the ground if you think about sylvie being the
alternate loki technically he's not wrong when he
says that he is going to burn this place to the
ground it just might not be him specifically but
the other reason why sylvie did all this with the
bombs as kevin feige said was to create the story
ripples that he talked about affecting future
marvel movies and series for instance silvie
didn't create the multiverse from the ground
up like there was a multiverse before this as
the ancient one said in the doctor strange movie
issues that the multiverse before this moment
was limited to the subset of alternate realities
that the time keepers had wound up in their sacred
timeline and deemed to be not dangerous the reason
why you can have one sacred timeline for the
entire multiverse is because they're being kind
of technical with the way they describe the sacred
timeline think about the sacred timeline as this
giant river like this might be a representation
of the sacred timeline in four-dimensional space
now imagine the current version of the multiverse
all these alternate universes are rocks inside
this river of time so to speak none of the rocks
are big enough to alter the greater flow of this
giant river of time and anytime somebody steals
an infinity stone like loki steals the tesseract
the space stone or the avengers steal the infinity
stones during end game and they do create branch
timelines things happen to create nexus events
in the flow of the river so to speak the sacred
timeline is diverted just a little bit that's when
the tva would get involved to erase those changes
the reason why they didn't arrest the avengers is
because captain america kind of did their work for
them he took all the stones back clipping the
branches so to speak as he says and then even
though he kind of took a left turn and went to
live with peggy carter in 1942 and nothing he did
before he came back to present day created a nexus
event and that's why the tva didn't move in to
stop him or arrest peggy carter so getting to the
events of spider-man no way home doctor strange 2
in the marvel what if series the way sylvie helped
set up the multiverse crossovers like spiderman
no way home spiderburst elements with all these
different versions of characters because we have
doctor octopus coming from the events of tobey
maguire spider-man 2 and alfred molina confirmed
he would be the same version of dr octopus and not
only that his story in the new movie would begin
right after he goes into the river at the end of
spider-man 2 and that was 20 plus years ago almost
like into the river then five seconds later it's
the beginning of spider-man no way home the only
way you can do that is with multiverse travel and
a little time travel and there been some reports
that the no way home title is actually meant to
be a reference to a couple ideas one of them being
the villains from these alternate universes like
jaime fox's electro from the amazing spider-man
films have no way home in the multiverse is
slowly collapsing in on itself that gets into
more of miss minute's speech about madness doctor
strange 2 plot the total collapse of all reality
but before the events of marvel phase 4 think
about it this way kevin feige had always made
it seem like he didn't have any interest in
doing big sony crossovers like he didn't want
venom inside the mcu he was content to let sony
make all the movies they wanted to just as long
as they kept them in an alternate universe like
we don't want to have to deal with all the stuff
that you're doing because we don't have complete
quality control over what you're doing but then
they signed that new spider-man sharing deal for
the new movies and suddenly he kind of changed his
tune saying that tom hall and spider-man would
not only be traveling the multiverse he'd also
be traveling between cinematic universes so we all
just expected them to say that all the different
spider-man franchises the tobey maguire spider-man
movies andrew garfield the venom movies all just
happening in alternate universes very simple way
of tying everything together it's just that now on
the loki series they're laying the track work
for why that is so for example several of the
time bombs that silvi sends to various points in
earth's history all of them were sent to points
in history long before present day the reason
why that's important is because if you create
branch timelines in the distant past they have a
better chance of creating present day versions of
the characters that are vastly different like
for example one of these is happening in 1947
in new york city on earth changed something in
the 1940s back then you theoretically have the
chance of creating a new alternate reality that
then leads to a very different looking version
of spider-man that just happens to look like toby
maguire or andrew garfield but you get the idea
on one level she's essentially creating universes
of the multiverse where the other sony spider-man
movies exist now but some of the other places she
sent these bombs to are really big easter eggs too
in their other places inside the universe like
ego the living planet sakar vormir asgard the
cree home world that's more of a lead-in for the
marvel what if series doctor strange 2 and then
theoretically other marvel phase 4 movies down
the road for example there's actually multiple
what-if episodes with different iterations of the
iron man character he died during avengers end
game in robert downey jr the russo's kevin feige
said they didn't want to want to trample on that
but during the what if series we're going to see
alternate reality versions of the character in
multiple alternate realities where things
played out very differently and he's still
alive in present day for instance one of the
episodes where killmonger is featured killmonger
instead of trying to steal the throne of wakanda
is supposed to get his weapons from iron man like
he teams up with iron man instead of trying to do
the vibranium plot tony stark i'm here to bargain
there's also supposed to be a completely separate
episode where another different universe version
of iron man gets sent to sakaar instead of
thor that's where this trash looking hulk
buster comes from he makes a hulkbuster to fight
in the contest of champions that's made of trash
so we'll just call it the trash buster for now but
then connecting things in a larger sense to doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness in that episode
one history video for the tva ms minute said that
if too many branch timelines are created it would
theoretically become madness another multiverse
war that was more literally a doctor strange 2
teaser but also kind of a hat tip for avengers
secret wars down the road but imagine doctor
strange sitting here watching all the time bombs
going off at the end of loki episode 2 from the
sanctum just slowly crapping his pants like what
is going on over there but miss minutes winds
up being correct chaos erupts and creates the
events wherein the different spider-man characters
from different universes all wind up on the main
mcu earth for the events of spider-man no way
home then it gets even worse and you start to
see the total collapse of all reality towards the
events of doctor strange 2 and that's where the
larger villain of doctor strange 2 gets involved
which theoretically right now has been reported
as schumacher he's a character that predates
the creation of the multiverse he was born in
the void of nothingness that existed before the
multiverse so when they talk about the collapse of
all reality it's sort of like everything returning
to the chaos of nothingness that came before that
obviously when you think of chaos you think of
wanda's chaos magic during the one division series
so don't worry i'll do more videos about doctor
strange 2 and all the stuff that's going on during
that when we get more footage but the writer of
the loki series also wrote the story of doctor
strange 2 so you can see now how it's connected
in this really large sense and why all these time
bombs were so important for them expanding
the multiverse in a really quick chaotic way
one of the reasons though why i think the vormir
easter egg is from the year 2300 is just that
there's no confusion about them bringing back a
version of black widow like no this is happening
hundreds of years in the future so she's still
dead they didn't want fans thinking like oh maybe
black widow's coming back to life because of this
change but let me know in the comments though do
you think that sylvie's time bombs are the reason
why the multiverse gets thrown into chaos setting
up doctor strange 2 and how do you think she sets
up spider-man no way home in the spider-verse
plot with the big crossovers speaking of other
connections too the showrunner on loki actually
came from rick and morty and rick and morty season
5 episode 1 is releasing tonight i will be doing
weekly videos for that so now we'll have loki
episodes and rick and morty episodes every week so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those episodes when i
post them if you still have big questions just
post them all in the comments below and i'll add
them to my future videos and i'll just keep the
giveaway open through all my marvel videos this
week everyone click here for my full loki episode
2 video and click here for my loki episode 3
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!